okay last game for today let's go for
you for for the last of the last match
yeah another three a shocking novelty
obviously be 60 ok let's sir let's play
open see what he comes up with you had
the time enough try some English a text
that up don't really know the
theoretical implications so i must admit
better let's just let's just play this
yeah actually a source our games with
it's like 96 or something interesting
I just play that typical dead simple
attacking that maybe don't threaten
anything but let's just push everything
for once and hope for the best now naija
form Amy's could be a good idea
therefore also we can this year okay
place before immediately there could be
could be very good move I couldn't go
here and not be one let's show but yeah
okay
hmm
okay what that let's just let's just try
this year then follow up with g6 and
suddenly completely incorrect but
least it has got him thinking somewhat
okay iea too but she cannot take a two
really ok let's just push 36 probably of
course that also his rook has got
activated but well yeah okay I was
thinking that um maybe not be sexist an
idea checking the rook and the palm
not sure what his son considering of
course it's a very complicated position
I can play lots of moves but i think was
just expecting work T 1 i'm just as
always thinking about the most you put
simple move just get this rook out of
out of out of the farm after all blacks
got exchanged and two extra pounds cage
Knight to f6 the of course so why not
why not KSK age 70
at least is some thank you yeah we will
play this now maybe I have some some
chances here on the on the long diagonal
question is should i should i take this
Rukia it's not a matter of material of
course but
how do I get this Bishop on the long
diagonal quickly we should to d4 need to
get to D 492 but I don't want to retreat
this piece looks bad Queen have two runs
and tonight f4 this is all so stupid
okay I grab this first didn't didn't
look at this at all of course
Bishop g5 yeah I got a telephone call I
hate it I just hate it if the phone is
ringing while playing a game I always
lose always I can't remember a game
which I didn't lose after the phone
started to ring yeah just resins here
yeah maybe it was bad anyway but I just
[ __ ] hate it sorry I just need to
switch this thing off right at just
blunder every time okay let's just check
this quickly if I have got at least some
swindling chances are something we
should f for the computer wants to play
okay this is just crap he wants to play
90 through of causes this attack is
completely incorrect but when I don't
know how this is this is played at some
one of those cases where simple recipe
like just shove everything for what it's
just not another thing okay well thanks
for watching the sum was somewhat rusty
performance I guess after the after the
break well i hope to the next the next
term gap between videos shouldn't be too
long well i'll see you soon i think